salut les pompes chose annulée pout
chasse si thomas lavado mal là-bas le
youtube à succès qui s'apprête à
dépasser le million de followers sur sa
page youtube tout l'espace de savoir ce
que va faire ton mal là-bas pour sa
vidéo du mil et aux grandes entreprises
mais jpa qu'on en direct sur ta chan si
je voulais tu sois la star de ma vidéo
du mignon
là on est tous choqués sur la dernière
vidéo qui a posté thomas lamah le mec a
fondu quoi ça va des tentes et abris
colas pas comme si je découvrais
lighters ouais mais là il y en a
vraiment beaucoup
on va sélectionner dix et on va aller
les voir pour de vrai dans la vraie vie
et on va voir si je me diront pas écrire
calculer à l'ordinateur comme de tirah
en [ __ ] j'y crois pas non mais vous
êtes qui thomas
qu'est-ce qui me l'a peut-être ben moi à
la base je voulais les mettre de grandes
gifles à tous mais en fait les paroles
plus je réalise qu'en fait tant qu elle
ceux qui ont la rage contre moi c'est
parce qu'ils ont la rage contre eux
mêmes je veux une grande barge antoniol
parce que juste le reflet de ce qu'ils
aiment rire et leur comble c'est moi
je pence
perso nagl franchement ta gueule